chewing me up  Jack Harlow is levitating after finally  meeting Dua Lipa who is the namesake for  a song from his second studio album come  home the kids miss you the two music  Superstars bumped into each other at  variety sixth annual hit makers brunch  where they were seen smiling chatting  and posing for photos together later on  during the ceremony Jack presented  Atlantic Records with varieties label of  the Year award but one thing I cannot  dispute is that I was given a real  chance to develop as an artist  Jack's song Dua Lipa features the artist  rapping about his affections for the  cold heart singer who is another one of  Atlantic Records artists  he's a European she know I'm seeing  extra got a man character but you could  be a extra yes sir Jack also gave Dua a  shout out during his performance at the  iHeartRadio Jingle Ball over the weekend  damn right you want to be in this scene  she had a video trying to be in this  city